and their struggles because of the Bucks
defense in fact they haven't better than
30 points
hookers Porter all there is not a strip
downtown come out early on is the honest
again going right MP that time I thought
it'd be backtracked a little too much
second-year man from SMU
and here is a youngish spinning his way
on mad hits up a lot of space and forces
you to have to keep bodies on him and
that I think helps honor the people also
have opportunities to attack the
backboard as he's able to attack the rim
there against in beef it's trees for AJ
Riddick
[Applause]
and the honest right banks get the Bucks
a two-point lead he now has 21 points
out that shifty reddit just did he was
tripping over his own foot and didn't
able to gather and finish much like
Yanis does there as he continues to
attack the paint once that will limit
some of the ways that he's attacking
offensive there sagging on Joelle
not comfortable taking the three do ice
lazy stories series and Yanis able to
knock down the the angle shot filling by
seven just under three and a half
remaining yeah it counts up the foul
what a move by me honesty now let's go
at Simmons banks it home help it in be
get closer that triple double
Hamrick down
[Applause]
Janice to try for three yes the lights
out for Beach they are now 15:29
downtown lavish tickets I vote chance
therefore City